this week's episode is brought to you in
part by the American Dental Association
teeth tell a story we know what ancient
civilizations ate drank even where they
lived all from looking at their teeth
what story will your teeth tell about
you you're a DA dentist can help you
find out and give you the tools to keep
your teeth healthy for years to come
use the American Dental Association's
find a dentist tool to find the right
dentist for you go to a DA org slash
science bag today this week's episode is
also brought to you by Startalk Allstars
podcast in a world filled with fake news
flat earthers and conspiracy theories
what's a thinking person to do think
like a skeptic of course on this episode
of star talk all stars neuroscientist
Heather Berlin and her comic co-host
Ari Shaffir investigate the importance
of skeptical thinking with their guests
Cara Santa Maria and dr. Steven novella
of the skeptics guide to the universe
remember
trust no one question authority and
listen to Startalk all stars wherever
you listen to podcasts for the rigorous
scientific thinking you crave
welcome to the science podcast for
November 16 2018 I'm Sara Crespi in this
week's show news writer and gibbons
discusses what could be the worst year
ever I'll give you some clues
we've got volcanic eruptions months of
darkness and a plague Meghan Cantwell
talks with Andrea DeFrancesco but his
review on fasting and metabolism could
we fast our way to a healthier old age
and David Malikov editor for the policy
blog science insider talks with senior
reporter Jeffrey Mervis about science
and the recent US elections now we have
N Gibbons and she's here to tell us
about a contender for the worst year in
the last 2,000 years I'm Sarah crispy hi
Anne hi Sarah I can think of some
contenders for the worst year you
mentioned in your story
13:49 pretty terrible year with the
Black Death and also 1918 which saw a
ton of deaths by a very virulent flu
what makes the year that you named in
your story stand out as a potential
worst year ever 536 according to
medieval historians was the darkest hour
of the Dark Ages or what used to be
called the Dark Ages and that was the
year where there's several historic
reports that a mysterious cloud came
wafting over Europe and plunged it into
darkness in the spring of 536 from basic
reports from Byzantine scholars
apparently the light dimmed the Sun gave
forth its light without brightness like
the moon it was as if there was an
eclipse
there was no summer that year the
temperatures dropped 1.5 to 2.5 degrees
Celsius which initiated the coldest
decade in the past 2,000 years Wow
crops failed people starved there was
famine it was not a good year that is a
bad year and some of these reports came
from well not completely confirmed but
from China from Ireland all over the
world people were not happy in 536
there's reports in China that the crops
were failing there there are reports
that Scandinavians left a cache of
golde as an offering to the gods to ward
off starvation in Mesopotamia where
there are people that are complaining
that their wine tastes like sour grapes
Oh
besides written accounts there are
physical clues elsewhere that this was a
terrible time for an example tree rings
indicating cold during this period now
there's this new ice core evidence
that's much more refined and specific
can you tell us where the ice quarter is
from and what kind of analysis is being
done on it yes so the new evidence is
coming from an ice core that was drilled
in the cone of Fetty glacier in the
Swiss Alps most of the research in the
past has come from polar ice cores like
in Greenland or at Antarctica this time
though they were able to go to a nice
car that was right smack in the middle
of Europe during this really dark period
and it preserves between 2000 and 4000
years of events in the atmosphere
whether they're climate change storms
Sahara dust storms meteor impacts
whatever it is whatever produced any
kind of pollution or chemical changes in
the atmosphere was captured a snow fell
in the Alps this record isn't just long
it's also very detailed so they were
able to with this new technique to look
at very very thin I guess you take
slices of time going back over this 2000
year period they use a laser to ablate
or carve out little tiny 120 micron
slivers of the ice along the length of
the core they're able to get something
like 50,000 samples from each meter at
that very fine resolution getting so
many samples from each layer even though
layers at the bottom of the glacier that
are more collapsed and squished together
they're able to get enough samples that
they can see not only every year but
they can even see at a resolution snow
that fell down sometimes to the month or
week and with that kind of fine scale
resolution they can detect all sorts of
discrete events year to year season to
season what kind of molecules what kind
of minerals what kind of isotopes were
they looking for in these miniscule ice
slices so at the University of Maine but
their new methodology they can look for
about a dozen different elements in the
ice core
sulfur and bismuth which are tossed up
by volcanoes they can look for lead
which is produced when you mind silver
they can look for all sorts of elements
that show whether there are dust storms
in the Sahara there's dust that goes
across Europe every summer and that will
tell them they're seeing a signal of
summer they can pick up all these
different elements and that can help
them tease out ancient climate or
volcanoes or pollution researchers have
long known that 536 was a bad year but
they didn't know what the source was and
they looked for comments they looked for
volcanic explosions they just weren't
sure but then with ice cores in
Greenland and the Arctic they were able
to look at those and they could see that
there was big increases in sulfur and so
they began to get a hint that there was
some major volcanic explosion around 536
540 but they weren't sure where it was
it was hard to sort of track it from
those polar ice cores so what has
happened now is researchers at the
University of Maine in Orono
famous glaciologist and and
volcanologist have gotten together with
historians at Harvard and archaeologists
in Europe and they are studying an ice
core that was drilled in the Swiss Alps
right in the middle of where all the
pain and suffering was so how does this
illuminate the story of the worst year
ever recorded what does it tell us about
the volcano or the volcano eruptions and
you know where they were located a
graduate student Laura Hartman at the
University of Maine in Orono found two
little microscopic particles of volcanic
glass in the Swiss ice core right at
about the time of 536 and they saw that
these little volcanic glass particles
had a chemical fingerprint that was more
like that of glass particles found in
lakes in Europe and those matched most
likely matched rocks and Iceland and so
that counted an earlier idea that
originally people thought it was a
tropical volcano that caused 536 then
later some people proposed this North
America so this is strong evidence that
suggests that the volcano actually
erupted in Iceland and then that the
clouds wafted over Europe after that not
everybody's convinced yet
some climate all just want to see some
more evidence before they are completely
convinced what about the plague I'm just
gonna throw that out there because there
was at this time this worst year and the
few years that followed there was
volcanic eruption
you know the darkened skies crops dying
and then also this Justinian plague
showed up how does that tie in with what
was happening with the climate so that's
really interesting there was the
eruption in 536 and then it looks like
there was a second eruption in 540 and
that one-two punch just prolong the cold
and the dark and the misery and probably
set people up not to be as healthy but
then also the plague broke out along the
Nile River in the Mediterranean in Egypt
and probably because the Byzantine
Emperor the Eastern Roman Emperor
Justinian was the Emperor started
shipping more grains because of the
famine hmm that included rats on the
boats and so that spread the plague
coming out of this major port city where
grains were farmed along the Nile and
helped spread the plague so you sort of
see this concatenation which is such a
great word concatenation of all these
events happening the darkness and the
cold crops fell people are hungry their
health isn't as good you start bringing
shipping and more grain from more
distant places the climate change sets
people up for illness and then we had 35
percent to 50 percent of Europe dying
from the Justinian plague and that
changes the entire way of life and
economy in Europe and it takes almost a
century for people to recover the
recovery of the continent is also
visible in this ice core yes it's really
interesting so around 640 they see a
surge in lead in the ice core which
means that the silver mines are
producing more silver again and that's
probably because they're adding silver
to gold coins because trade is going up
and they need more coins to make that
trade happen and then is 666 60 there's
another much bigger surge of lead which
means they're really cranking up the
silver mines and that's because there's
a switch from the gold standard to the
silver standard Wow because I need more
money because there's a lot more trade
going on on the ports in Europe at that
time driven by merchants so that's the
big beginning of the medieval economy
which is very interesting
yeah we can see the medieval economy in
a nice core that's just amazing this
really seems to be almost a new era as
one researcher also mentioned in your
article we can look at such fine scale
resolution of these ice cores and look
at all these different isotopes and
contaminants in the ice do you think
we're going to continue to see more
records like this going forward
absolutely this is going to start a
whole surge of researchers trying to get
the ice cores from glaciers that are
melting all around the world before they
melt
right yeah from Africa to Europe
wherever they can get these ice core
records before they're gone because
there's so much important information in
them I'm going to a workshop next week
at Harvard where they're going to talk
about some other findings are people
saving some of these cores for when we
get better at analysis or are they
getting the cores and then basically
destroying them in the process of
figuring out what is in each layer or in
each time point so the very cool thing
about this new methodology used by the
team is that their new method they use
does not destroy the ice core they take
such tiny slivers of ice the computer
helps them track to write where they
took it from the precise spot and a lot
is preserved most of it's preserved so
this is a new method where they're not
melting it to do the analysis which is
fantastic so it will be there for future
analysis that's great thank you so much
Anne you're welcome my pleasure and
Gibbons is a contributing correspondent
based in Pittsburgh you can read her
story at news that science mag org stay
tuned for Megan cam wells interview with
Andrea DeFrancesco
on his review a time to fast which is
part of a special issue this week on
metabolism
[Music]
this week's episode is also brought to
you by the NSA almost every day we hear
something on the news about a
cyberattack sometimes it's just a bunch
of pranksters but more often it's a
foreign country with vast cyber
resources trying to hack the power grid
the banking systems were the military's
information networks the National
Security Agency plays a big part in
protecting the country from cyberattacks
and you can help the NSA is hiring
technical professionals to serve on the
front lines of information security if
you work in computer science networking
programming or electrical engineering
you can help keep the country safe
design new hardware systems and networks
right faster smarter programs protect
America's critical infrastructure or
help uncover what its adversaries are
planning to do next learn more about
careers at the National Security Agency
today visit intelligence careers gov
slash NSA that's intelligence careers
gov slash NSA this week's episode is
also brought to you by ops Genie
incidents happen and they require
complex coordination between operations
and software development teams who are
putting out fires every day that's why
getting alerts immediately is critical
thankfully there's ops Genie by
Atlassian ops Genie empowers dev and ops
teams to plan for service disruptions
and stay in control during incidents it
also gives teams the power to respond
quickly and efficiently to unplanned
issues and helps to notify all the right
people through a smart combination of
scheduling an escalation pass that
account for things like time zones and
holidays
better yet ops genie allows for deep
flexibility and how when and where
alerts are deployed with over 200
integrations like JIRA Amazon CloudWatch
data dog New Relic and more plus it
tracks all activity and provides useful
insights to improve future incident
responses with ops Genie your next
incident doesn't stand a chance
visit ops Genie comm to sign up to get a
free company account and add up to five
team members that's ops Genie comm Oh PS
GE n I
Icom never miss a critical alert again
with ox Jeannie I'm with Andrea
DeFrancesco to discuss how adjusting
meal size and/or frequency could
contribute to a healthier and longer
life
Andrea hi how are you doing how are you
I'm good thanks
so when did researchers begin to
investigate this link between dietary
interventions and reduced chronic
illnesses associated with aging the
studies started almost in the 40s 50s
have shown that in rats that were fed a
limited amount of calories can have a
longer lifespan those studies were
repeated in several other organ is
ranging from very simple yeast
roundworms fruit flies to higher animals
including mammals this research kind of
started in rodent models and then yes on
to other mammals what are the types of
chronic diseases that have been shown to
be impacted by dietary intervention
protection from cardiovascular disease
and diabetes hypertension these are all
benefits that are told to be associated
with the weight caloric restriction and
your review doesn't just discuss caloric
restriction also known as CR but it also
explores other types of dietary
interventions like fasting right there
are other forms of dietary intervention
that can be used and this include the
time restricted feeding which refers to
the reduction of exposure to food within
24 hours and then there are other forms
that are called intermittent fasting or
periodic fasting when people or animals
alternate days of normal feeding today
so fasting the last intervention we
discuss has been recently developed at
is called fasting mimicking diet
mhm and so that last one how is it
different than the other forms of
fasting instead of having a complete
fasting you have a significant reduction
calories in this regime ian is adopted
in a periodic way so the fasting mimic
diet is adopted for five days and it's a
every month or every three months or two
times a years it depends on who needs
this type of diet so what are these
specific mechanisms in the body driving
these reduced risks for chronic disease
in response to fasting or caloric
restriction the organ is respond to a
stress it activates systems where the
organism is allowed to repair damaged
tissues at the intracellular level to
get rid of damaged molecules this is
seen in pretty much all day for
intervention
were there any adverse side effects that
anybody found in these studies yes
actually one of the cautious notes that
we add to the review is that people
should not adopt these regiments without
a medical supervision for the caloric
restriction we know that it may impair
the immune system so candle a buidling
may have effect on osteoporosis and
sarcopenia the timing of these
intervention in terms of what age people
should start or stop this intervention
is very important because for example in
all people caloric restriction can be
actually detrimental yeah that was one
question I had from the review is that
since most of these experiments were
conducted on non-human models how does
it translate to human models is it
something you would have to do when
you're younger or this is something that
once you're reaching an older age you
start this kind of intervention so for
example in mice what we know is that
when you start our restriction early on
in life
after the organs is completely developed
you have life span extension this is not
always true the mice that are able to
live longer are those that are able to
keep higher resources of fat
this is because the mouse metabolism is
somehow very different from the human
metabolism and so people should be
careful when they try to translate the
observation obtained in mouse animal
models to humans are there any cultures
that naturally have this low-calorie
diet or fasting lifestyle and as a
result have experienced better health
outcomes as they age you know do us
people that have a mutation in the
growth hormone receptor they are
significantly protected from a number of
disease and they have a small stutter
and this is also true in the Okinawan
population that is specific population
in Japan these people they adopt caloric
restriction these people have some of
the resemble some of the characteristic
of models of CR the number of
centenarians in the Okinawan population
more than doubled and the population in
Japan right so you've seen through how
people who are fasting or restricting
calories just because that's culturally
what they're doing have aged healthier
or live longer but are there challenges
to seeing this through actual human
experimentation like is it hard to get
humans to participate in these trials
newman's of course it's very hard to
have lifespan studies like we do in mice
so there are short-term clinical trials
and here
you see a reduction in body temperature
reduction in body weight is typically
associated with with the CR reduce the
inflammation reducing metabolic rates so
there are some some aspect that we see
in animals are also seen newman's
whether now these will translate into
lifespan extension we can not say that
okay these results are pretty promising
but like you said this would have to be
done under supervision of a doctor
making sure that you're doing it the
right way what are the next steps for
this research that would potentially
allow it to become more adopted by
mainstream population people that
consume their meals within a twelve
hours window in the day
are protected the Henshaw some of the
metabolic protective alteration that are
seen in people on caloric restriction
even if they eat the same amount of
calories and this is very important
because in this case you don't have a
demanding intervention for the
individual that has to adopt basically
that can play just on the timing of
eating so just eating from like nine
o'clock in the morning to nine o'clock
at night and that would be the fasting
period so it's correct correct and vice
versa we also know that in studying
people where that have like a night
shift or have neurotic lifestyle and so
they eat for in a window of time 15
hours they typically also are more
likely to develop metabolic disease and
this is has something to do with with
the alteration of our internal clock
that regulates cycles of fasting and
feeding resting and activity so there
are satisfied specially by sacha bandha
that have shown how in mice when you'd
mutate some element of the clock mice
having issues in terms of their
metabolism essentially there are ways to
do this without being as extreme as some
of the other previous ways you've
mentioned and could still yield some
similar benefits yes so the idea is to
have intervention that are more feasible
that can involve periods of fasting
within the 24 hours or two days in a
week it's clearly more feasible than
your entire life from garlic restriction
right for sure thank you so much for
speaking with me oh thank you for having
me
Andreea DeFrancesco is a postdoctoral
fellow at the experimental gerontology
section and translational gerontology
branch at the National Institute of
Health you can find a link to his review
at science mad or slash podcasts
stay tuned for david Malakoff and jeff
Marissa's policy discussion on the US
election which scientists candidates won
the day and what are the implications of
the election for science funding and
policy
[Music]
now we have science deputy news editor
David Malikov and senior reporter
Jeffrey Mervis discussing the results of
the u.s. election and the future of
science policy thanks Sarah
so I'm here with Jeff Purvis a senior
correspondent at science I'm David
Malakoff a deputy editor on the news
staff Jeff big election last week
millions and millions of people went to
the polls so let's start with the big
picture what happened the big picture
was that the Democrats regained control
of the House of Representatives and at
the same time the Republicans held
control of the Senate so you know you
and I have been tracking about 50
candidates this year who have some kind
of technical background they might be an
engineer they might be a physician to
science and research so how did they do
in the end who won who lost well out of
those 49-7 won last week now the first
cut of course were the primaries and
only about 19 of them made it through
and each of those victories were unique
to their district but they ran in part
on their scientific training they wanted
voters to know that they felt that would
be an asset when they entered Congress
yeah so on our website we list the seven
winners let's talk a few a little bit
about those winners who would you like
to start with well there's Shaun Caston
in the sixth District of Illinois
outside of Chicago this was one of the
most expensive races in the country each
candidate raised and spent over six to
eight million dollars Wow he won a tough
primary and then in the general election
he talked a lot about energy efficiency
talked a lot about climate he criticized
his opponent incumbent Peter Roskam for
his votes on health care which was an
issue that all Democratic candidates
hammered but he he injected a fair
amount of science and climate policy as
well dissents Election Day you talked to
Sean Caston what did he tell you about
what he wants to do now that he's a
member of Congress as all of the
candidates that one
told me even though they're
scientifically trained they represent
their district first and foremost and so
if their district has a large military
presence they want to be on armed
services if they're interested in health
care they want to be on the Energy and
Commerce Committee or ways and means to
set tax policy it doesn't mean they're
going to abandon their scientific
training but they're not necessarily
going to want to serve on house science
committee
yeah let's come back to the committee in
a minute I was curious about another
candidate that who I believe you talked
to Joe Cunningham down in South Carolina
he was one of the upset winners on
election night nobody really expected
him to win that race in red South
Carolina but he used environmental
issues to his great advantage it appears
during the during that contest he did
indeed David IgE as you said it was a
very Republican district it's also a
very coastal district covers much of the
coastline of South Carolina and his
opponent early on made a comment during
a candidate forum saying she supported
President Trump's proposal to lift the
ban on offshore drilling well that gave
Joe Cunningham the opportunity she later
reversed herself but it seems to be in a
very potent issue in fact not only to
Joe Cunningham I emphasize it but a new
group that was formed a couple of years
ago to help scientists who wanted to run
for office a group called 3/14 action
put nearly one-quarter of all of their
money from their political action
committee into a last minute campaign
that emphasized the Republicans position
on offshore drilling most people think
that was decisive yeah so there's a case
where 3 3 1 for action made a difference
potentially in a big race so you did
mention earlier that this Democratic win
in the house is going to mean big
changes there in part for the House
Science Committee which is the committee
that sort of oversees the science
agencies it doesn't set their budgets
but it does help determine policy and
traditionally the leader of that
committee has sort of set the agenda for
some of the science policy issues that
are being discussed under the Republican
leadership of Lamar Smith from Texas
who's retiring that committee became
sort of persona non grata
in the scientific community the new
presumed chair Eddie Bernice Johnson a
psychiatric nurse from Texas says that
one of her goals one of her first goals
is to restore the credibility of the
science committee now in the face of it
you'd think oh my goodness what does she
mean what she means is that the
committee sometimes became the
laughingstock and the butt of jokes on
late-night television because some of
its members driven by ideology would
throw out comments like sea levels are
rising because of erosion of cliffs
right and rocks going into the water
representative mo Brooks made that
remark yet that was just an example of
how the hearings that the science
committee held were often so ideological
that they weren't interested in
exploring the issue they weren't
interested in hearing the facts from
nonpartisan scientists so much as
hearing representatives of Industry or
representatives of a particular faction
and then in contrast the Democrats would
criticize those views and the impact of
the witnesses was nil because it didn't
they never changed anyone's mind a lot
of stakeholders the community itself
just sort of threw up their hands and
said there's no point interacting with
this committee we're not going to get a
fair hearing and they're not going to
move any legislation that is based on
science so a big change in tone and
substance of how science committee all
of the other committees will also get
Democratic leaders the appropriations
panels that set spending levels but Jeff
what does it mean in terms of prospects
for real legislation in other words the
house is going to be controlled by
Democrats Republicans are going to
control the Senate President Trump still
sits in the White House is this gonna
just be a time of gridlock with nothing
getting done or are there chances for
some bipartisan deal making well I think
most people feel that in terms of
climate change in energy policy it's
going to be gridlock at best what the
Science Committee now the committees can
do is tea up issues and hope if they're
Democrats that a Democrat wins the White
House in 2020 and they can move
legislation there are some other issues
infrastructure being among them where I
think some
people still hold out hope that was
something the president Trump said he
was interested in his plan has gone
nowhere but it's an important issue
because scientific infrastructure was
part of the stimulus bill from 10 years
ago and scientists are hoping that any
infrastructure bill that moves through
this Congress or the next Congress could
include money for scientific facilities
went with highways and dams you get a
couple of scientific laboratories maybe
a new Collider correct it doesn't even
have to be shovel ready which was the
term a decade ago it just has to be
important for keeping up with the
infrastructure needed to continue to
innovate and for the u.s. to continue to
be a scientific leader so Jeff to
closeout we've talked about the winners
on election day and we talked about
what's likely to happen in Congress but
what about the folks with technical
training who ran put their heart and
souls and often a lot of money into
these races and then came up short on
Election Day
right well the quintessential candidate
in that category is a professor of
biochemistry at the University of
Mississippi named Randy Watkins he was
the Democratic nominee but he was facing
more than an uphill battle it was a
mountain running not just against an
incumbent but in a district where the
incumbent had won by some 40 points the
Democratic Party was moribund and he had
very hard time raising money so he had
three strikes against him but what he
feels is that it may have been the most
important thing he's ever done science
wise and this is someone who's been a
professor for 25 years and by that he
means he got people out speaking about
science speaking up for science as well
as helping to to rebuild the Democratic
Party and the way he puts it he said
this is not the end of scientists
running for Congress it's just the
beginning I think that's a good note to
end on that was deputy news editor David
Malkoff talking with Jeffrey Mervis a
senior correspondent for science news
and that concludes this edition of the
science podcast if you have any comments
or suggestions for the show write to us
at science podcast at ASOR G you can
subscribe to the show anywhere you get
your podcasts or you can listen on the
science website that science math or
gosh podcasts to place an ad on the
science podcast contact mid-roll comm
the show was produced by Sarah Crespi
and Megan Cantwell and edited by Potter
G Jeffrey Cooke composed the music on
behalf of science magazine and its
publisher atrabilious thanks for joining
us